وينضم الينا من لندن الكاتب الصحفي في
جريده الشرق الاوسط بدر القحطاني سيد بدر
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض وفق يعني ما جاءت به الشرق
الاوسط حول مسوده خطه السلام الشامله
نسال هنا يعني وفق ما جاء في هذه
المسوده وفق ما سرب ايضا للشرق الاوسط هل
من ضمانات الالتزام الحوثيين بتنفيذ بنود
هذه هذا الاتفاق او هذه
المسوده وكيف تقراها قبل ذلك
مساء الخير
التي اجرتها السعوديه والدبلوماسيه
السعوديه بمشاركه عمانيه وكانت منذ وقت
طويل جدا
[موسيقى]
يعني من وجهه نظر شخصيه في اطارها الشامل
بدي هي وقف النار طبيعي جدا للدخول في اي
عمليه سلام موضوع الهدنه الاماميه كانت
السابق تتحدث الامم المتحده عن سته اشهر
اعتقد تفاصيل التقنيه والتمديد الى عام
كامل مع التزام جميع الاطراف سيعود بالنفع
على الجميع بطبيعه الحال
التفاصيل الى الى اللحظه ليست حاسمه وليست
نهائيه ولكن من الله جدا
قليله جدا في اليمن كان كثير من الفرقاء
يحاول ان يصل الى المطامع السياسيه
واطماحه
واهدافها بالعنف اليوم نحن نرى الفرقاء
اليمنيين
بمختلف
مشاريعهم وتوجهاتهم الجميع يحاول ان يحقق
من كاسب سياسيا عن طريق الحل والسلمي
والحوار
والتناتي على بعض هذه القضايا لكن دعني
اسال عن الفترات الزمنيه ثلاثه اشهر ثم
سته اشهر اربعه مراحل هل هذه المدد
الزمنيه فترات كافيه لحلحله هذه الازمه
والوصول اخيرا الى مرحله الى حل طبعا
يعني سياسي وبعد ذلك ايضا انتقال الى
المرحله الانتقاليه اخيرا كما جاء في هذه
المسود الفترات الزمنيه وهذه المده كافيه
دعني اجيب اولا على السؤال الاول موضوع
الضمانات من المستحيل وجود ايضا حتى لو
الاعلنت ايران بنفسها انها تضمن البعودين
هذا لا يعطي ضمانه لكن من المهم جدا اعطاء
المزيد من الفرص للحلول السلبيه هذه نقطه
النقطه الاخرى مساله تقسيم المراحل المهمه
جدا لان
مع الخبره والسنين الحرب
مساله الهدن المفتوحه والملفات غير
المزمنه دائما
ما تنور بالفشل وتنور ايضا
بتفسيرات بين مختلف الاطراف لهذا السبب
بغض النظر عن كم هي المده على لكل مرحله
هي سنتين ام سته اشهر او سنتين نفسها تقسم
على سته اشهر بغض النظر عن هذه التفاصيل
التي لم
يرد هذه
المبني الثقه وتعيدها لان كثير من الاطراف
لمده ثمانيه وتسعه اعوام وهم على خلاف من
غير من غير الوارد ان يتفقوا فجاه وان
يكونوا على وفاق الامر الاخر امر احيانا
السياسيين عندما يتفقون على الامور لا
نراها تنعكس مباشره على الارض فبالتالي
هذا يعطي مساحه ومسافه للقرارات
والالتزامات بان يتم ترجمتها من اعلى
الهرم الى القيادات
يعني ربما هذه المسوده لم تتحدث عن الوضع
العسكري الحالي او كيف سيكون الوضع
العسكري ايضا حتى في الايام المقبله وهي
احد احدى ربما الاشكاليات خلال الايام
الماضيه بالتالي كيف يمكن التعامل مع
الاوضاع العسكريه الترتيبات ايضا كيف ستتم
هل
ستسبق او ستكون هناك شروط مسبقه لاي دخول
في الموضوع العسكري او اي حلول ايضا اما
انه سيكون من ضمن يعني ما سيتمخض عن هذه
المحادثات ربما او
الاجتماع بين الفرقاء والجلوس على طاوله
حوار سياسي
برايك سيد بدر
ايضا مطروحا للدراسه وهي عباره عن لجنه
عسكريه وامنيه تدرس مساله الناحيه
العسكريه ولكن لا ننسى ان وقف اطلاق النار
هو اهم عمليه عسكريه اصلا ستمهد لكل
الاصلاحات السياسيه او الاقتصاديه او
الانسانيه او حتى التنمويه المقبله سواء
داخل المرحله الانتقاليه او حتى قبلها فمن
دون وقف لاطلاق النار من كل الاطراف لن
تعني الاصلاحات السياسيه او المراحل
الانتقاليه اي شيء ستكون مجرد تاجيل
للصرافه مستقبل بينما لو بدات بووقف النار
والتزام به فستكون هذه علامه المستقبل في
اي سياق وضعت قضيه الجنوب في هذه المسوده
برايك سيد بدر
قال الجنوبي في صباح اليوم
ان هناك اجتماع عقد بين الاعضاء الجنوبيين
في مجلس القياده الرئاسي وهم عيدروس
الزبيدي وعبد الرحمن ابو زرعه
وعبد الله العليمي باوزير
ولواء فرج المحسن وهؤلاء تم تشكيل لجنه من
قبل مجلس القياده الرئاسي
بعضويه الاربعه الى عقد
كل الاطر المناسبه لان تكون قضيه الجنوب
قضيه حاضره واحده من الملفات الرئيسيه ضمن
الملفات التي يتم نقاشها في الحل اليمني
وهذا اعتقد انه تقدم لافت لان نعرف ان
الفرقاء الجنوبيين انفسهم
لديهم وجهه نظر مختلفه فعندما يجلسون على
الطاوله ويتحدثون بالسلم وبالسياسه نرى ان
هذا تقدم كبير في الازمه اشكرك جزيل الشكر
من لندن الكاتب الصحفي في جريده الشرق
الاوسط بدر القحطاني شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات